i'm particularly concerned about the
number of cases in london
kent and essex cases are rising
and in many areas already high looking
into the detail the testing results and
surveys show us that by far the fastest
rise is amongst secondary
school-aged children 11 to 18 years old
while the rate amongst adults in london
is broadly flat
but we know from experience that a sharp
rise in cases in younger people
can lead to a rise amongst more
vulnerable age groups
later we've seen that happen before
so we need to do everything we can to
stop the spread amongst
school age children in london right now
we must not wait until the review which
will take place on the 16th
of december we need to take targeted
action
immediately having spoken to the leaders
of
london's councils and to the mayor we've
decided to put in place an immediate
plan
for testing all secondary school age
children
in the seven worst affected boroughs of
london in parts of essex that border
london
and parts of kent we want to keep
schools open because that's both right
for
education and right for public health
we're therefore surging mobile testing
units
and we'll be working with schools and
local authorities to encourage
these children and their families to get
tested over the coming days
more details will be set out tomorrow